What shocking death is set to reshape the
future of the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe?
Who turned out to be someone other
than who they said they were?
Multiple times? Keep watching to find out!
The big reveal in "Iron Man 3" that the Mandarin's
true identity was not who it appeared to be
became a polarizing moment in MCU history. Love
it or hate it, the moment was one most viewers did
not see coming – and nearly a decade later, would
become a major plot point in a different MCU film.
When trailers were initially released for
the third film in the "Iron Man" series,
fans learned the Mandarin would be joining
the franchise; a longtime comic book adversary
for Iron Man, his appearance felt as
inevitable as it was straightforward.
Yet, Mandarin had a slippery history when it
came to his racial origins in old comic books,
and the casting of Oscar winner Sir Ben
Kingsley seemed to indicate, for some,
a possible whitewashing of the character
that might just make matters worse.
Ultimately, Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark
discovered the supposed leader of the Ten
Rings was an actor named Trevor Slattery, hired
to terrorize Stark in the guise of the Mandarin.
A self-centered coward who saw the Mandarin
as "just a role," he was a smokesecreen for
Aldrich Killian, the ultimate mastermind behind
this particular Mandarin terrorist threat.
While fans were torn about this
re-imagining of Iron Man's arch-nemesis,
many enjoyed Slattery's antics, and a Marvel
One-Shot short depicting his life in prison
and subsequent abduction by the "real"
Mandarin was well-received. Consequently,
Marvel surprised fans once again a decade
later — by making Kingsley's Slattery a
significant supporting character in 2021's
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings,"
continuing his storyline as a prisoner of the
title character's father, the real Mandarin.
As the MCU came to dominate the box office
throughout the 2010s, Marvel also made
inroads via a mostly separate but parallel
world of TV, releasing series like "Agents
of SHIELD" on broadcast networks and streaming
platforms. While "SHIELD" sometimes reacted to
events in Marvel movies or featured cameos by
the likes of Samuel L. Jackson as Nick Fury, a
partnership with Netflix yielded six interrelated
series that had even less to do with the MCU
Despite not being closely tied to the movies,
though, shows like "Daredevil" were well
received. But at the beginning of 2019,
the Netflix production partnership was
dissolved and all the series were canceled.
One of the casualties was Vincent D'Onofrio's
portrayal of the classic Marvel supervillain
Kingpin, which had earned rave reviews from
fans and critics alike. But it turned out
that the folks at Marvel Studios were also big
fans of D'Onofrio, because in December 2021,
he made a surprise debut in the MCU proper as
a major figure in the Disney+ show "Hawkeye."
That was followed almost immediately by
"Daredevil" star Charlie Cox making a cameo
as Matt Murdock in "No Way Home," opening
the door for other discarded Netflix heroes
to make their return, and cementing
those shows as official MCU canon.
"Avengers: Age of Ultron" may not be
the most warmly-regarded MCU outing,
but it did offer some unexpected
plot points that would shape the MCU.
Chief among them was the death of Pietro
Maximoff, brother of Wanda — aka Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch — who spent most of
the movie battling against the Avengers,
but ultimately became sympathetic
characters. Fans were as shocked
as Hawkeye when Pietro gave his
life to save the avenging archer.
"Bet you didn't see that coming."
Much like the Mandarin, this plotline
would be revisited nearly a decade later,
much to the surprise of MCU fans,
as Wanda's trauma over Pietro's
death became a major plot point
in the Disney+ show "WandaVision."
Oh, and it also led to the dumbest fakeout in
MCU history, as Evan Peters' alternate universe
version of Pietro turned out to be just some
random guy. C'mon, MCU, you can do better!
"You're… Ralph Bohner?" "Boner."
Peter Quill is essentially an overgrown adolescent
frozen in the intergalactic fantasies of an '80s
kid who watched too many movies. His obsession
with Earth pop culture — fueled largely by the
mixtapes his mother left him before her death
— has him dancing his way through heists and
other adventures of the "Guardians
of the Galaxy" and wider MCU films.
However, when he became caught up in a galactic
battle between Xandar's Nova Corps and Ronan the
Accuser in the original 2014 "Guardians of the
Galaxy," most fans were just getting to know the
character — and likely expected a final act fueled
by weapons, explosions and superpowers, not dance.
Singing and shimmying in front of the warlord,
Ronan became so confused that it allowed the
other Guardians enough time to blast Ronan
and retrieve the Power Stone. It was a memorable
exclamation point on Pratt's now-iconic character,
and all these years later, the
"Guardians" haven't lost their groove.
Pop culture has been telling us for more than
three-quarters of a century that superheroes
must keep their identities hidden —
the concept even predates Superman,
stretching back to heroes like Zorro, the
Lone Ranger and the Scarlet Pimpernel. So,
viewers took it for granted in 2008, when the
original "Iron Man" came out, that Robert Downey
Jr.'s Tony Stark would do everything in his power
to keep Iron Man's true identity on the down-low.
But the movie ended with Stark addressing the
world's media at a press conference, distancing
his gaze from the index cards in his hand and
announcing instead with a twinkle in his eye
"I am Iron Man."
It was not only an early signal that the MCU
was willing to take big swings and diverge
from the superhero playbook, but also spoke
volumes about the nature of this cocksure hero.
Stark simply isn't the alter-ego type,
and in hindsight, his inability to stop
himself from taking credit for Iron Man was
perfectly in keeping with who he'd become.
One of the most harrowing moments in the MCU
occurred when Steve Rogers' best friend Bucky
Barnes was killed in action during World War
II in "Captain America: The First Avenger."
So it turned out to be a welcomed surprise
when the title villain in "Captain America:
The Winter Soldier" was revealed
as Cap's long-lost friend.
Steve's astonishment reflected the feelings
of many viewers, especially since the movie
was set decades after Steve had last seen Bucky.
The revelations came fast and furious as Bucky
was not only alive and looking young, but also
working for HYDRA after being kept cryogenically
frozen through the decades. Naturally, Steve and
Bucky's previously established friendship helped
goose the rest of the movie, making the pair's
climactic confrontation all the more poignant.
Nick Fury was an integral part of the plot of
"Spider-Man: Far From Home." He was the one who
sought Peter Parker out while he was visiting
Europe, recruiting him to team up with Quentin
Beck, the up and coming superhero known as
Mysterio, to stop the Elementals. Following
the collapse of S.H.I.E.L.D., Fury was depicted
as having been driven into the shadows, but doing
his best to continue to enlist superheroes
to eliminate ongoing threats to the world.
So, how shocking was it to learn that
Nick Fury wasn't Nick Fury at all?
The film's post-credits scene brought with it
the revelation that Fury may have been less
invested in protecting Earth than the
rest of the movie led fans to believe.
It showed Fury and his loyal associate Maria
Hill changing into the forms of the Skrulls
Talos and Soren. Their conversation then revea
led that Fury had deployed the shape-shifting
aliens to do his job while he pursued some kind
of mission in space with the rest of the Skrulls.
"Everybody back to work!"
While many of the villains of the MCU haven't made
much of a lasting impression, Michael B. Jordan's
take on Eric Killmonger in "Black Panther"
proved to be one of the exceptions. For the
first half of the film, the character seemed to
be just an American mercenary after vibranium.
But ultimately it was revealed that
he had been playing a long game,
patiently waiting for an excuse to enter Wakanda,
because he was actually T'Challa's cousin
and thus had his own claim to the Wakandan throne.
And more: his father had been killed by T'Challa's
father, who then abandoned Killmonger and left
him behind in America to fend for himself.
Even though he was willing to destroy
and kill to get what he wanted,
Killmonger's circumstances and his desire to carry
on his father's mission to help the oppressed
made him impossibly sympathetic. In fact,
the fate that awaited him was probably met
by as much disappointment from MCU fans
as any sense of triumphant comeuppance.
As a result, the character remains one of
the MCU's most potent and memorable villains.
It's funny how a seemingly throwaway scene in
2015's "Avengers: Age of Ultron" ultimately
became the one best remembered from the film.
Perhaps it's because the moment was thrilling,
quite funny and would later pay off
with a major reward — all emblematic
of the unique formula MCU films
tap into at their finest moments.
During a party at Stark Tower early in the
film, the Avengers jokingly attempted to
lift Thor's hammer, Mjolnir. As we all
know, the ability to wield the hammer
isn't just a simple matter of strength —
the individual has to be worthy to do so,
with a combination of heroic qualities that
Mjolnir can magically detect. So, it came as no
surprise when none of them could lift the hammer,
though it did twitch when Captain America tried.
But later in the movie, it's revealed there's one
character besides Thor who
can handle Mjolnir: Vision.
After stealing a synthetic body
Ultron had created for himself,
Stark and Banner uploaded Stark's loyal
A.I. program J.A.R.V.I.S. into it,
with Thor channeling the lightning
necessary to activate the body.
Of course, many of the Avengers were suspicious
of this new being they dubbed Vision. After all,
he had at least some of Ultron's consciousness
inside him, so how could he possibly be trusted?
Easy answer: by effortlessly
lifting Thor's hammer,
Vision immediately proved himself worthy of
their trust, and had fans cheering in the aisles.
It seemed inevitable that at least one or two
characters wouldn't make it through "Avengers:
Infinity War," yet few could have predicted
the movie opening with the slaughter of at
least half of what remained of Asgard — and the
main villain of the MCU up until that point.
After Thor's home was destroyed during the
events of "Thor: Ragnarok," the citizens who
remained behind sailed into space, only
to encounter Thanos and his followers.
The sequence became even more
shocking when the newly reformed Loki
attempted to kill Thanos, only
to be strangled by the Mad Titan.
Thankfully, through a mix of
time travel and multiversing,
an alternate universe Loki would eventually
live on in a self-titled Disney+ series.
But that didn't lessen the pain of losing the Loki
who went through "Ragnarok" in "Infinity War."
In "Captain America: Civil War" Helmut Zemo
went to work employing what he knew about
the Avengers to tear them apart. Key to his
plan was showing Tony Stark a video from the
night in 1991 when his parents died in a car
crash, as it showed that their deaths happened
at the hands of Bucky Barnes, acting on
behalf of HYDRA as the Winter Soldier.
While viewers had seen Bucky being sent to carry
out the Starks' executions earlier in the film,
the knowledge he had killed them was trumped
by the heart-pounding slow-burn sequence where
Tony learned the truth. Viewers, Captain America,
and Bucky had all hoped Tony wouldn't find out,
given it wouldn't do him or the other Avengers
any good, and it was gut-wrenching to see Cap
and Iron Man turn on each other, their
friendship shattered in a single moment.
"He's my friend." "So was I."
When Peter Parker picked up his crush Liz at her
house for the homecoming dance in "Spider-Man:
Homecoming," he was as shocked as
the audience when Adrian Toomes,
the illegal arms dealer he had been trying to
stop, was revealed as Liz's father. Could Peter
keep his wits and get out of the situation with
his life, secret identity, and prom date intact?
The moment is magnificently
orchestrated by director Jon Watts,
who builds tremendous tension with things as
simple as rear-mirror close-ups and the shades
reflected from street lights. On the surface, it
appears as though Parker still has the advantage;
as with any Keaton character, however, this man
is no fool. You can see the wheels turning in
his mind as the light of recognition finally
illuminated the deadly confrontation to come.
"You walk through those doors, you forget any
of this happened, and don't you ever, ever
interfere with my business again."
Peter Quill lost his mother to cancer at a young
age and never knew his father... until "Guardians
of the Galaxy 2," when he learned that his
father was the Celestial Ego the Living Planet,
and that Peter was in possession of the
same extraordinary powers as his dad.
Initially, Ego came across as the warm
parent Quill had been missing for most
of his life — but eventually,
his true nature became known.
Ego revealed that he was responsible for
causing Quill's mother's illness and death,
something neither Quill nor viewers expected.
After all, Ego had claimed he loved Quill's
mother. Yet, as Ego himself would point out, when
you're a Celestial who is millions of years old
and only getting older, you don't experience
love like a mere mortal. In Ego's mind,
this may have made his actions reasonable —
but for Peter, it was the ultimate betrayal.
Looking back at the breadth of the MCU, there have
certainly been plenty of fan-service moments. But
it's hard to think of one that garnered more
applause and excitement than the "Avengers:
Endgame" scene when Captain
America proved himself worthy.
Remember how Cap was able to budge Thor's
hammer way back in "Avengers: Age of Ultron?"
Well, by the time "Avengers: Endgame"
arrived, the stakes had become so much higher,
as the team tried desperately to
restore the half of all life that
Thanos had snapped away. So when the trio of
Thor, Cap, and Iron Man confronted Thanos,
with the Mad Titan moments from ove–rcoming
Thor, Cap's revelation that he may have been
more worthy than he let on back in "Ultron"
brought joy to both Thor and viewers.
"I knew it!"
"The Avengers" was the first time Marvel's
various superheroes teamed up on the big screen.
Given the excitement of seeing the
team assemble for the first time,
fans didn't anticipate the emotional gut-punch
of seeing Phase 1 fan favorite Phil Coulson
end up on the wrong side of Loki's scepter.
Coulson's death gave the film real stakes,
and the uneasy team of superheroes something
to rally around. For fans who loved the
steadfast agent, though, Coulson's demise
gave "The Avengers" extra emotional heft.
Of course, he went on to lead the TV show "Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D.," making Coulson not only one of
the first iconic MCU characters to die, but also
the first to be resurrected. And more than once!
Nick Fury and S.H.I.E.L.D. became major
forces throughout the first many MCU movies.
Throughout that time, fans had been
led to believe the organization was a
force for good — as did the Avengers. Such
clear lines of good and evil came crashing
down with "Captain America: The Winter
Soldier," however, amidst revelations that
for decades a parasite had been feeding
on S.H.I.E.L.D. from the inside: HYDRA.
"Hail Hyrda!"
When Captain America and Black Widow went
to seek answers at a S.H.I.E.L.D. facility,
they found themselves in an underground lair.
There, a computer with Hydra scientist Arnim
Zola's mind explained Hydra's decades of work
within S.H.I.E.L.D., an admission that allowed
him to brag while distracting the heroes from the
missiles on their way to destroy the facility.
Ultimately, it took the destruction of
S.H.I.E.L.D. to eliminate the threat from Hydra.
Given all the battles he has fought in the
MCU, it's easy to forget that Peter Parker
is still a teenager. So when the revelation
of his identity as the man behind Spider-Man
compromised the college acceptances of him
and his friends in "Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
it made sense that he wouldn't think
through all the possibilities to
remedy the situation — and that Doctor Strange
wouldn't double check that Peter had exhausted
every other option before coming to him
for a magical solution to his problem.
Unfortunately, by the time Strange completed
the spell to make the world forget Parker
was Spider-Man, things had gone haywire and
the door had been opened to other universes.
It would be a mess that could only
be undone with a very adult decision.
By the end of the film, Peter had worked with
Strange to finally make everyone forget about him.
It was a choice that left him isolated, alone,
and clearly entering a new era for the hero.
The third "Spider-Man" film in the MCU was packed
with surprises, from the web-head teaming up with
his counterparts from the previous "Spider-Man"
franchises to a "Venom" series tie-in. But one
of the most unexpected moments in "No Way
Home" turned out to be much less about
the stunt-casting and more about hard-earned
audience affection for an ill-fated character.
In every Spider-Man story prior to the MCU, the
death of Uncle Ben had always been a catalyst for
Peter to become a hero. But without a Ben in
his origin story, the MCU's Peter had instead
been in the care of Aunt May— and had seemed to
discover his fate without a comparable tragedy.
Until now.
When May encourages Peter to help the villains who
have arrived in the MCU from alternate universes
instead of sending them home to die, Peter
follows her advice. But when Green Goblin
takes control of Norman Osborn's body, Aunt
May pays the price. Among her final words?
"With great power, there must
come great responsibility."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.